hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen and today I
am watching Young Frankenstein for the
first time I've spoken a bit about what
I kind of grew up watching and Star Wars
and Indiana Jones and animated Disney
are on the list but also two movies that
I watched countless times where Wizard
of Oz and Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory and Gene Wilder sadly passed and
he is a comedic genius doing stuff that
nobody was doing back then and nobody's
is doing now really just a whole other
level so I figured I should probably get
with the times and maybe see Young
Frankenstein my gosh these lips are too
green
can't do it can't do it guys it's too
much it's distracting me that's a little
better
less green maybe that's worse looks like
I've eaten a cupcake or something so
beautiful um yeah so anyway I am very
excited to see this movie I always have
hesitation watching super old movies
because it's kind of like going back to
a really old video game I'm going back
to like an old console I was I was
playing n64 recently and I see oh man
this was my childhood but gosh dangit if
these graphics don't suck
similar kind of thing so I'm always like
oh man I'll just sit through it it'll be
fine
my dad made me watch casablanca as a kid
and i was like i did not want to do that
he's like just sit through it it's gonna
be great and it was great so i very high
hopes for this movie and it's about time
i watch it so let's see how it goes
Oh tanner has never seen I cannot
believe how much I enjoyed that movie oh
my gosh
holy crab it was so funny everything was
so detailed
and hilarious wah-wah
tell people apparently so you start off
on gene Wilder who is playing Fred
Frederick Frederick is his name it's
playing Frederick Frankenstein because
he wants to distance himself from his
grandfather Frankenstein he's a
brilliant scientist and he's teaching a
lesson and he gets very very upset about
this student asking about his grandpa
Frankenstein
so upset that he picks up a scalpel and
just stabs his leg with it and then he's
like alright guess we're done here
class is dismissed and then this really
weird guy that I don't think you ever
see again comes up to him and brings him
a box
I don't remember what's in the box
either this movie really impacted me
apparently
and he's like you've gotta go to
Transylvania
for your grandparent your Grandpa's
wishes so he goes before he goes there's
this incredibly funny scene between him
and his fiancee Elizabeth and they're
saying goodbye but she doesn't want him
to touch any part of her because she's
going to a party and she doesn't want
him to ruin her makeup or her hair or
her dress and it's so funny and real
relatable hashtag gleeful I really enjoy
it just off the get-go how funny the
first female character is that you have
an interaction with I think that's I
can't read this there's lipstick in her
oh ok um he gets off the train in
Transylvania and I gore meets not Igor
his Igor's grandson I gore meets him at
the train station and it's hilarious
he's such a good character this movie is
a delight then you meet Inga and she's
hilarious and adorable then you mean
Frau Luka who every time her name is
said horses neigh even if she's not
around horses it's a wonderful gag
really funny super simple super funny
you're in the castle and the set is out
of this world
crazy good set costumes super incredible
the hilarious bookshelves
named hilarious I always wanted a
bookshelf where you like pulled
something out in the lever and it's like
a surprise passageway I wonder if I have
that all right I'll see what we got here
you see levers anywhere
that's a viet best bisexual erotica
what's that doing there I'll just take
that find the lever another time here so
was it a boss - and a bank where were we
so they find Frankenstein's old lab and
they're going down this staircase it's a
really cool scene but honestly all I can
think about and watch is Inga's bed gown
it is on point looking good girl
I want to thank you I'll be right back I
think it's the closest thing I could
find it's the fallout onesie it's so
green what tastes delicious hmm that's
way better okay don't look like a
sparkly alien oh I want to look like a
sparkly alien okay
anyways so then they find his Grandpa's
library and he's like wait a second I
don't want to distance myself from
Frankenstein I want to be Frankenstein
so he's like I'm gonna make a monster
myself and then the movie makes the most
funny simple penis joke ever executed in
film well that goes without saying
well that goes without saying well that
goes without saying so they gray rob a
body and then I Gore tries to get a
brain and he he breaks the brain that
Fred wants and so he gets a brain that
she says abnormal brain do not use
super simple but hilarious I loved it
set the bucket so at first the monster
isn't alive and then it wakes up after a
few days oh my god the sedatives
charades scene is so brilliant and
hilarious also they're very good at
charades so this point the monster
sedated but Frau Blanco or whatever it's
lets him go and it's revealed that she
was dating Victor Frankenstein and it's
a hilarious reveal because she's like
yes he was my boyfriend which is just
hilarious term for her to use this movie
is a Gigi delight I love it AF doesn't
even work this movies funny AF that's it
that works there we go
working around that YouTube censorship
so they're able to capture the monster
and Fred decides he needs to let the
monster know that he's loved and that's
how he's going to be an accepting and
kind monster and he's like you're
handsome buddy
and the monsters response to being
called handsome is when somebody calls
me pretty in real life like mmm so then
Fred and the monster become best friends
and they put on a pup pup they put on a
demonstration for the public and it is
perfect it's perfection holy crap the
mix of dancing and singing and comedic
brilliance that you get from gene in
this scene is out of this world it's
completely ahead of his time Moo so good
so then the audience starts booing him
and he gets ashamed and scared and the
monster freaks out and everyone's mad
because he's freaking out now and it's
kind of hilarious like it's this once
dead monster come to life dancing and
singing for them they're like that's not
enough he's like oh god I'm really
embarrassed that you don't like me very
much and so he gets a little upset
obviously and then
you'd Shane him up sad so after that to
console him Fred sleeps with Inga which
has been building the whole time and
then they get word that Elizabeth is
coming into town
in a couple minutes oops the monster
ends up taking Elizabeth from her room
in the castle to some cave somewhere I'm
not sure where it is but then they
totally do it
seven times and it's a hilarious scene
at first I thought it might be going in
the way of kind of like rapey vibes and
felt that way at first but it was not
that and it was super funny and she
sings opera when she's having sex just
up first I've never seen anyone do that
I've seen other things then though they
lure the monster back to the castle with
music and they are trying to help him
have a more brain so fred is like I will
give him some of my brains and so they
put the helmets on and little roofies
and tubes technical term for it and they
conduct this experiment but all of the
public is like there with like
pitchforks and they're all mad and they
come in and they turn the experiment off
but right at that time the monster had
got enough brains and he stands up and
makes this really wonderful and touching
speech about anger and love and what his
purpose is and how much he appreciates
Fredrik and it's very nice and Frederic
marries Inga how it was supposed to be
and the monster marries Elizabeth and
it's hilarious and at the very end they
may put the button on top of just like
Angus like Fred he got some of your
brain so what did you get in return
penis joke so a couple things I really
really loved about this movie it
surprised me I'm like I said I'm always
kind of hesitant to watch older movies
it shocked me with how raunchy it was
but tastefully raunchy I guess I'm so
funny
everything was hilarious i Gor oh my
lord so funny you met the policeman when
they were like grave-robbing and he was
so funny a small part and then the
police chief guy with the wooden arm
hilarious also all of the women were
super funny which I really appreciate
so they were still like to the romantic
interest but they're not like just boobs
on screen like it Elizabeth was
hilarious and way different than Inga
who was hilarious and then Frau Cobra or
whatever it was so funny and good they
were all incredible comedic actors it's
really sad that we lost this incredible
comedic wonderful human being
who will let her make anything ever
again but he left us with such
incredible performances and movies that
are so fun and good and they make you
think about things and they like make
you ask questions and as a performer
they really inspire you to kind of step
out of your box or like step out of the
box and make really great things and hey
could be worse
could be raining
worth it
[Music]